Speaker 1: All right. I have some amazing video
for you today. Now, if you're allergic to cringe,
I would tune away, but if you relish it, if you
live for the cringe, then this is the segment
for you. I've been talking now for a very long
time about how the Republican Party has moved
away from even pretending to be about policy. This
sort of started during the civil rights movement
in the late 50s, 60s and into the 70s.
You can actually trace Republicans not
being about policy all the way back
to that. But in the more modern era,
the Republican Party abandoning policy was
accelerated when Newt Gingrich took over
the control of speakership of the House of
Representatives in 1994, when kind of dimwitted
George W. Bush became president. Republicans moved
further away from being about policy and instead
being about cultural issues, et cetera, and memes
and slogans. When Barack Obama became president,
his being half-black triggered so many of the
more racist and xenophobic right wingers that
the focus further went away from policy and more
into personality stuff and culture war issues. And
under Donald Trump, they pretended to even care
about policy. And Joe Biden pointed this out at
his press conference last week. Remember Joe Biden
saying, What are Republicans for? Remember this?
Speaker 4: Think about this.
What if Republicans for?
What are they for? Name me one thing they're for.
Speaker 1: So Jake Tapper did something great.
He had Republican Senator Joni Ernst on his
program. She's from Iowa. Excuse me? And he said,
Can you name three things that Republicans
actually stand for? All of these Republicans are
furious with Joe Biden because he said they're
not for anything. But tell us three things that
you are for. And it is as wild and vapid as
you can imagine. Let's take a look at this,
and we're going to go piece by piece here.
Speaker 3: So Senate Minority Leader Mitch
McConnell has said he does not feel that
Republicans need to present an agenda to the
country. And generally speaking, I understand
the politics midterms tend to be referenda
on the people who are running the country. But
what are three things that Republicans will do
if you recapture the Senate in the midterms?
Speaker 5: Well, I think that Republicans stand
for a strong, free and prosperous nation and
Speaker 1: a free, prosperous nation. OK,
well, let's talk policy.
Speaker 5: So one we need to
tackle the issue of inflation. Biden is facing
a 40 year high with the inflation rate, and
Iowans and all Americans are feeling those
pressures. So alleviating those pressures on
our families would be job number one COVID.
Speaker 1: So, OK, now when you listen to
what she did there, she identified a
problem that's not a policy and it's
not a solution. She says inflation is high
under Biden. And so we would reduce inflation.
OK, but that's that's not policy. Governments can
use wage and price controls to fight inflation,
but that can accelerate a recession
and create job losses. You can look
at contractionary monetary monetary policy to
fight inflation. Reduce the money supply. Look
at bond prices in the interest rate. She's
identified a problem. How would you solve
this cardiac issue that this person is having?
Well, this individual's having a heart attack,
so we would deal with that. No, right. But what
I'm saying is, what is it that you would do
to fix and deal with the heart attack? OK? That's
number one. It's just stating a problem. Let's
continue, she said. Now she's going into COVID.
Speaker 5: Well, we need to make sure that
American families have access to testing,
but certainly we want to make sure that they
are getting their children back into
school and that their workplaces are
are safe and they can return to work.
Speaker 1: Now understand that that's
completely vapid. First of all, she didn't
care about testing when testing was a disaster
under Trump. So, you know, that's number one.
Number two, most schools are open. Some schools
have gone temporarily remote. Some have been
forced to close because too many teachers got
COVID. And there's nobody there to teach.
There's nothing. There's no policy there.
Speaker 5: And then as well, we need to focus
on additional things like, you know, foreign
relations with our allies because obviously
with national security, we are under a lot of
pressure right now. So Republicans believe that
Speaker 1: that is nothing. You're not saying
anything. She says the three priorities would be
bringing down inflation, but she doesn't say how
fighting COVID when she didn't care about
that under Trump and doesn't actually say
what would be done, and most of the things she's
saying she wants to see are already happening,
like most schools open and workplaces open. And
then they would do foreign relations. They really
aren't for anything. She was given an opportunity
she could have said. What we are going to do very
specifically, is we will change or we will we will
try to get the Fed to change direction on interest
rates, which we believe would get inflation from X
to Y. We would do this or that on, even if they're
crazy things like we would force schools to be
open and be penalized, like even if it's crazy.
Say what you will do given an opportunity and
has nothing, literally nothing. They aren't for
anything. Joe Biden was exactly right in
pointing that out, but the crazy part is.
They might still take over the House
and Senate, even not being for anything,
because it's not clear they need to be for
anything. The vast majority of their voters
don't care that they aren't for anything, and
that's really the scariest part of all of this.